books authors and the publishing
industry
every weekend here on c-span too
now biography on book tv looks at the
life of astronomer carl sagan who died
in 1996
recently two authors published
biographies of mr sagan's life and work
key davidson wrote carl sagan alive and
william poundstone wrote carl sagan a
life in the cosmos
both biographers were hosted by the
skeptics society at the california
institute of technology where they
talked about carl sagan's scientific
ideas and methods and about his personal
and family life
their discussion lasts over an
hour uh so i have to do the introduction
stuff anyway i'm michael schumer the
director of the skeptic society and the
publisher of skeptic magazine we are
hosting
a special on carl sagan with the
publication of his two biographies by
william poundstone and key davidson and
uh we're gonna spend the hour discussing
uh carl his life and and what it means
and so i got to thinking uh about this
whole subject of what is the measure of
a life
when it is gone
uh an obit in the newspaper a short
story in a magazine a tribute from
family friends and colleagues a potted
television biography
500 page book
how should we capture the essence of
that life a list of accomplishments
highlights and low lights
interviews with family friends and
colleagues and a few critics thrown in
for good measure
a womb to tomb narrative
and if that life was extraordinary a
life of greatness an epical creating
life how is a contemporary biographer
to put that life in perspective when the
epic is still going on
what tools should we use oral history
interviews demographic and statistical
compilation
document analysis
what field should we consult psychology
sociology cultural history
does the measure of a life depend as
much on who is doing the measuring as it
does on the measured life itself
or can we actually get to the meaningful
core of a person can there be a science
of biography
well i was reading barbara tuchman's
book a distant mirror and she had an
interesting statement at the beginning
of this book about the convolution of
history in fact how contradictions are a
part of life not merely a matter of
conflicting evidence
she says i would ask the reader to
expect contradictions not uniformity
no aspect of society no habit custom
movement development is without cross
currents
starving peasants in hovels lived
alongside prosperous peasants and
feather beds children are neglected and
children are loved knights talk of honor
and turn brigand
amid depopulation and disaster
extravagance and splendor were never
more extreme
no age is tidy or made of whole cloth
and none is more checkered fabric than
the middle ages
that's beautiful barbara tuckman writing
but we can apply this to a single life
as well no life is tidy or made of whole
cloth and none is more checkered fabric
than carl sagan's
one problem with narrative biography
is determining whether a description of
one subject by a colleague a friend
family member represents a long-term
personality trait or a short-term
temporal state
was carl sagan a tender-minded liberal
or was he a tough-minded careerist
was he a feminist or misogynist was he
really obsessed with the possibility of
extraterrestrial intelligence or was
this just a passing fancy that happened
to generate a lot of media attention how
can we tell
the problem is if you start off with the
hypothesis it's easy to mine the data to
find quotes and examples that fit what
you're looking for to slant a particular
history to go one way or the other
now the dream of a historian or social
scientist is to have it all in one place
to look at and fortunately for us carl
sagan was
almost obsessive with keeping track of
everything he did most curriculum betas
are you know 12 15 20 pages 50 pages
this is carl sagan's curriculum vita
it's 265 pages single space typed
so i mined the data not to test any
one hypothesis but just to kind of look
at a life uh with from from some
statistical points of view so you could
start off with something simple like
this
uh these are sagan advisory groups
professorship lecture ships professional
societies by type
total 293 137 advisory groups this is
anything from
um
you know a board of advisors for like
skeptic or the humanist or whatever to
professional groups lectureships
professional societies editorial
positions patent designs
26 short biographies and now two
full-length biographies and they're both
here today
we can look at
carl sagan
fellowships awards and prizes by type
one quite a few total of 89.
but but what but what did he get him for
that that matters because what was it
that was important to him that people
rewarded him for number one
humanitarianism humanism and peace
uh this is all the environmental stuff
that he worked on nuclear winter and so
on a popularization of science and
education which he's probably most
famous for
his scientific research outstanding
overall achievement 13 of them only two
for scientific writing however numbers
don't just
just say at all one of those two is the
pulitzer prize so
that's not so bad i think
we can look at uh honorary degrees by
type you got honorary degrees a number
of them in fact 23 total 14
a doctorate of science and so on and so
forth 23
total i i should note that um
that these statistics only really matter
in context i mean one of the questions i
was interested in is why was carl not
nominated to the national academy of
science how would he compare to other
members of the national academy of
science well i call the national academy
of science i call the triple a s and
they just don't have that kind of data
other people do and i just didn't have
time to put all that together but so
what i did was i called three prominent
eminent scientists all members of the
national academy of science you all know
who they are
jared diamond ed wilson and ernst meyer
so by comparison sagan has 23 honorary
doctorates
ed wilson
has uh
let's see
ed wilson has 26 honorary degrees which
he was happy to tell me one of the uh
one of the characteristics of a of a
great man is of a driven careerist as it
were is you keep track of your
statistics i mean pete rose and some of
these fanatical baseball players they're
famous for this and and and a 265 page
curriculum vita is a great example of
this uh wilson knew right off the top of
his head uh yeah 20 you know 23 for him
i i had 26. when i talked to ernst myers
meyer's 95
years old
and uh
so he's had a few uh 35 years more than
carl 34 years more than carl accumulate
these things nevertheless
he said i only have 16 but
mine are the cream of the crop
my doctorates are from oxford and
cambridge and harvard and yale and
bologna and you know bologna is the
world's oldest university okay ernst i
got it
uh i mean these guys you know they
didn't get to where they are by being a
lack of self-confidence
um
we can look at books i did a content
rating of carl sagan's books
i mean what's he interested in what's he
writing about planetary science the most
ten he was a planetary scientist first
and foremost that was his most
conservative thing that he did uh but
exobiology and the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence eight
books general science six nuclear war
environment five two on evolution uh i
should say that twelve of these were
solo authored the other nineteen are
co-authored uh so sagan was very good at
uh at working with other people and
sharing uh ideas and and data oh i i
should put by comparison here
ed wilson has 23 books
nine solo author eight co-authored six
co-edited ernst has 21 books 13
so authored and four co-author but
ernest was quick to tell me that one of
them was 900 pages long okay
and i'm telling you at 95 he did not
have to go to his notes to uh
explain this to me uh sagan scientific
articles by content 500
publications 67 publications in science
or nature science and nature the two
most
prestigious journals when you go to the
www.science
and look at the criteria for what you
should consider before you submit your
paper
they ask you is this the most important
thing you've ever done
is this the most original work you've
ever done and have you told nobody about
the results then you can consider
sending it in all right 67 of those is
not bad
i should i should note that this
includes abstracts which is a little
unfair the my other guys jared diamond
and ernst meyer and ed wilson did not
include abstracts in their cv and they
felt that was a little bit of a cheat so
when we actually do the comparison and
by the way before i put that up
planetary science again number one a
priority in his scientific publication
almost double uh the second one of
exobiology at 158 said i broke out
exobiology from seti as two different
things most of the exobiology papers are
having to do with uh with the origins of
um chemical origins of life things like
that not extra actual intelligences and
then 16 papers on nuclear winter and
nuclear war so clearly again he's a
highly regarded conservative planetary
scientist he's not out there on the
fringe uh like that at all now when you
compare it to the other guys
um
carl in context
career scientific publications i took
out the abstracts that puts them at 412
compared to ed wilson at 380 jared
diamond at 549 and ernst at 704 and
ernst new immediate as of today 704.
um
the uh
the the rate of publication oh i think i
forgot to print out my uh no i have it
here uh the rate of publication is
slightly different jared's no i didn't
print that out jared's is uh actually
the highest if you do publications per
year because ernst 95 and jared's just
55. so
jared's comes out at 13.4 a year carl's
is 10.3 uh ed's was 7.2 so carl's
certainly in the in the ballpark of the
most eminent scientists today not the
highest but but but it also shows you
what a highly regarded scientist jared
diamond is as well
uh if you look at his this was quite an
interesting thing this took me almost
all day saturday to do this this was
carl sagan popular articles by content
forget that it's 1380 it's a typo 271
was the highest one
the most written about thing by carl in
non-scientific publications these are
just um
magazine articles and so on is uh seti
and space exploration that was his true
passion not not just his scientific
passion but his personal passion there
and there it is the data speak for
themselves actually the number two most
common thing written about was sagan
himself
uh
263 interviews or profiles of carl and
or his wife
anne and then nuclear war in winter is
pretty close to that as well as social
commentary i broke these out environment
nuclear war is one social commentary is
like women's rights abortion rights free
speech things like that and then all the
way down the exobiology is quite small
compared to these over here so again
that gives us a feeling for where his
interests lie where he vested a lot of
his time
carl sagan scientific popular articles
by ear question is is did he lose
scientific credibility and productivity
after cosmos and becoming such a
productive popularizer of science the
answer is no and you can see it in the
data here's the big spike cosmos heirs
number of popular articles but the pace
of his scientific production continues
throughout i mean there's little
fluctuations throughout as there are in
all careers and there's a little dip
just before 1980 because of course when
you're producing a 13-part series for
pbs there's no time to actually do the
research so there's not many papers
coming out just after that but but he
gets back on track so
uh he was accused of being a mere
popularizer and not doing real science
not true there it is and these are all
and these are peer reviewed and again
science and nature are in there
finally uh i wanted to look at um
carl sagan personality again if you say
you know he was tough-minded careerist
or was he a tender-minded liberal
supporting women's right wha wha what
was he well one way to answer that
question and i'm going to kind of go
through this quickly but this all being
the next my next essay and skeptic uh in
which i sort of look at all this a
little more detail frank soloway and i
frank is here a social scientist uh
wherever frank went uh where'd you go
frank
oh there he is back there frank sullivan
uh thank you for coming frank from uc
berkeley
um frank and i did a mailing to um
a bunch of carl's family members of
friends colleagues and asked them to
fill out this this is what's called the
big five personality scale what we're
measuring is conscientiousness
agreeableness openness to experience
extroversion and neuroticism and they
were to ask they were to answer the
question i see carl sagan as someone who
was and then a scale of one to nine not
dutiful dutiful trusting suspicious
interested in the arts organized
disorganized and so on these 40
adjective pairs then
reduce down to these five different
personality
dimensions and then from that you
correlate them and then you correlate
the raiders to see the consistency
between the raiders i mean if
one if if they're scattered all over the
board he was liberal he was conservative
then what can we say but the correlation
that frank ran for me on these was a .74
correlation between the raiders which is
in social sciences that's plenty high
that's respectable that's enough that we
can say something intelligent about carl
sagan's personality in context of the
large the population at large which
frank soloway has a database of over 7
000 people in his computer so we just we
just rank carl by his raiders compared
to his personality for example on
conscientiousness he's at the 88th
percentile
of the general population very high in
conscientiousness very low in
agreeableness okay
uh so he's tough-minded uh he'd rather
be right than nice i guess it'd be one
way to say it uh he's willing to stand
up and and uh you know for what he
believes to be true he can be
hard-headed
that kind of thing uh the other
significant one was it was quite
interesting 97 percentile openness to
experience wow i mean to be a pioneer in
a science in a field you really need to
be open to experiences these two are not
particularly significant although in
neuroticism there is the compulsiveness
uh component and i think that's probably
pretty high as evidence of this is data
uh
i should know too in that in that 1380
popular science articles are included
articles not about carl but about a
subject in which he was interviewed
and when i told that to jared and ed and
ernst they just groaned they would never
include something like that
uh because it's not something he wrote
and it's not an interview with him so i
think those that spiked a little bit
high but of course that's a product of
being famous you get called a lot but
the actual keeping track of it
is a clue for us about his personality
this is somebody who is really a
hard-nosed careerist and he's keeping
track of all the data everybody that
called him and so on and had somebody to
help him with that so now
in the context of his particular
revolution his
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
i did this search carl sagan in context
with the seti pioneers is a book called
the seti pioneers
uh in which uh some of this data was
collected the birth order data was
collected i then got the rest of it
through the book and some other sources
let me break that down for you so you
can actually read it
carl in context the seti pioneers you'll
see an interesting development here this
is birth
birth rank and total sib ship size first
first of two first of two first of two
two of two but older sisters so first
born son first of three second of two
but again firstborn son first of two
second of two again firstborn son first
of two only child second first of two
two of seven one of seven one of two
only one of three now
the author of this book makes the
observation isn't that interesting there
seems to be a product a preponderance of
first borns in the seti movement
but he but he never asked the obvious
next question
is it significantly greater than what
you would expect in any other population
which so by itself it's completely
meaningless but thanks again to frank
soloway there's an actual test you can
run a statistical test and you figure
out what this population size is you
know what the general population size is
the average rate of first borns and so
on and you do the calculations and it
turns out this is
statistically significant at the 0.05
level it's not as good as 0.01 but still
it's statistically significant that this
is more first borns than you would
expect by random chance
at a statistically significant level now
so what what's going on with first borns
well as frank shows and born to rebel
those kinds of personality
characteristics
uh
conscientiousness in particular and that
tough-mindedness as measured in this
sort of low agreeableness are typical of
first borns but what about this openness
to experience well
first borns are just the birth order is
just a proxy for other things going on
for example if you have high conflict
with your parents
then you're more open to it than you're
then you're more like a later born than
a firstborn carl didn't have high
conflict with his parents got along
great with his parents his mother loved
him adored him and that's a big part of
the biographies it's fascinating um so
what else is going on well he's raised
jewish and members of oppressed groups
tend to be more liberal more supportive
of liberal causes and so on in fact as
we saw on the statistics on the things
he published
and popular articles in particular that
he wrote he was very socially liberal
extremely socially liberal
and so that would explain the openness
to experience and then the final thing
i'm not sure and i'm still playing
around with this in my mind this whole
seti thing what is seti
i mean all of these guys believe that
there probably are extraterrestrial
intelligences or else they wouldn't be
in that field right they wouldn't have
been pioneers in the field they wouldn't
be working in it but they were all asked
in in that book on the seti pioneers do
you believe in ufos not one of them i
mean there was a tiny bit of
equivocation oh maybe you know who knows
but probably not and and so they they
believe in the sort of a sort of a high
class uh uh highbrow form of
of extraterrestrial not the not the
lowbrow abduction stuff with
crop circles and stuff like that um
so finally i'm
i was looking at their religious
backgrounds all of these guys were
raised in some sort of religious family
church of england anglican orthodox
several jews course sagan was jewish and
they're all atheists all of them well
all of them were non-believers it was
difficult to code because they didn't
ask directly to infer it from the
interviews in this book but they were
all at least non-believers or i couldn't
tell from
or they just came out and said i'm an
atheist and carl was certainly pretty
strong about that
so i'm speculating and i can't prove
this but it's just sort of an
interesting idea and our biographers can
comment on that if they wish um that
study is almost a quasi religion kind of
spiritual movement in a way
um there's absolutely not a shred of
evidence of extraterrestrial
intelligence i suspect like most people
that they're probably out there but but
yet driving that is this idea that
there's something transcendent to us a
higher intelligence of some kind and uh
and and that they've got it they've
somehow survived
destruction of their environment and and
the ecosystem in themselves and so they
must be wiser than us more intelligent
than us they're almost
deified i mean that's what you see in
these science fiction
uh novels and films and it's a little
bit of that in context to be sure
um anyway so that's just have a little
fun with with a weekend in in carl sagan
cv
uh
uh of course that that isn't a life uh
humans are storytelling animals and the
story is really where the action is the
narrative in which you take that data
and weave it into a story and that's
what our our two guests have done today
so we have two wonderful um uh speakers
today uh william poundstone and keith
davidson so we're going to start off
with with william poundstone and his
biography from wiley carl sagan a life
in the cosmos
oh oh oh oh yeah right sorry but anyway
come on up
you want to stay at the podium okay
well thank you
uh one of my first editors told me
something that i've always remembered he
said that there's a maxim in the world
of publishing that you've got 10 seconds
to sell a book
you'd better be able to explain whatever
is new and exciting about your book
faster than someone can pick up a remote
well i've remembered that because it's
really scary to anyone who who tries to
write a serious book
i've written what i'd like to think is a
nuanced account of the life of carl
sagan and the thing that everyone seems
to focus on and you may be ahead of me
is that carl sagan smoked marijuana
well now don't get me wrong i thought
this was a perfectly good revelation as
biographical tidbits go but it certainly
has gotten a lot of publicity and and it
seems to to interest people
in general it seems that there's a
feeling that marijuana just doesn't sit
with the image that people have of carl
sagan
sagan was almost our culture's living mr
spock the embodiment of science and
rationality that there was this other
side to sagan seems to have upset a lot
of people
well i'm often asked to account for this
seeming paradox if such it is
well today i'd like to do so in a little
more detail than uh than the usual sound
bite and since this is the skeptic
society i'd like to look at how sagan
and marijuana may or may not tie into
skepticism
well when i first started writing this
book i had no idea that marijuana was
going to be part of it i knew only that
sagan was a very private man
no full-length biography had been
published in his lifetime and that's
kind of amazing when you consider just
how famous he was and that we live in a
society where ricky martin rates half a
dozen biographies
well now sagan rates two so i guess
we're making progress there
one of the very first people i
interviewed for the book was dr lester
grinspoon
now grinspoon is a harvard medical
school psychiatrist who was carl's best
friend for most of his life
in fact carl credited lester with saving
his life once during a hospital stay
so in a very real sense if it wasn't for
grinspoon uh we probably wouldn't even
be here today talking about carl sagan
i might also add that uh grinspoon was
involved in many of sagan's skeptical
interest
uh it was actually grinspoon who got
permission for sagan to listen to the
hypnosis tapes of barney and betty hill
the first celebrated case of alien
abduction
and uh 30 years later it was grinspoon
and sagan who tried to convince their
harvard colleague john mack
that alien abductions were fantasy and
not reality
as you may have noticed they failed to
convince mack of that
but these are sidelights on grinspoon's
career he's by far best known as a
leading advocate for the
decriminalization of marijuana
now you're probably thinking hi was this
grinspoon who turned sagan onto
marijuana
well actually i found out it was almost
the opposite
i first met dr grinspoon in his
cambridge office
i'm not quite sure what i expected him
to be like uh i guess the only mental
image i had was timothy leary another
harvard man
well grinspoon is really nothing like
that uh he's now in his 60s and he
certainly dresses as conservatively as
you'd expect a harvard doctor to dress
but he also has this very accessible
regular guy look and manner to him
that maybe isn't so typically harvard
anyway he told me that he first met carl
at a cocktail party in the mid-1960s
now the conversation had turned to the
war in vietnam
and despite what you probably think
about harvard in the 60s practically
everyone there was all for the war
the two who weren't were carl and lester
so they ended up introducing themselves
well at that time carl sagan was a brash
young astronomer on his way up in the
world
he was already advising nasa on its
missions to mars and venus
but is really his personal and
professional focus was the so-called
science of exobiology this is defined as
the study of life beyond the earth
now the problem with exobiology then and
now is that they didn't really have
anything to study
but
but but sagan was pretty convinced that
there was a good chance of life on mars
and he was dead set on being part of the
scientific team that would discover the
first martians assuming that the
martians cooperated by being there
well lester grinspoon was about to
embark on his own quite different
professional crusade
at that time the use of marijuana was
increasing among young people and as a
psychiatrist he was alarmed by that
trend grinsmoon had the idea of
compiling a truly scientific case
against marijuana and publishing it so
that people would realize what the
dangers were
but as this work progressed uh
grinspoon's ideas about the drug made
almost 180 degree turn
now this was for many reasons he found
first of all that there had been few
scientific studies of the drug
the few most credible ones failed to
demonstrate the sort of hazards that
were widely being claimed grinsman's
work culminated in the 1971 book called
marijuana reconsidered
i think this book is interesting for a
skeptic to read uh even if you're sure
it's dead wrong and it's not going to
convince you of anything
well anyway uh
grinspoon uh
found that sagan served as almost a kind
of walking object lesson for him
uh when they met sagan had been using
marijuana for half a dozen years
grinspoon had never tried the drug at
all
and the thing that impressed grinspoon
was that sagan seemed to defy all the
stereotypes about pot smokers
uh far from being laid back sagan was
the most extreme sort of workaholic he
was certainly a man with a sense of a
scientific mission to accomplish
and sagan was apparently able to use the
drug in sensible moderation without any
obvious ill effects
well one chapter of grinspoon's 1971
book concerns uh literary accounts of
people's experiences with marijuana now
for the most part grinspoon excerpted
these from the writings of people like
baudelaire and alan ginsberg
but grinsman got the idea it would be
great if carl would write his own
account
well somehow he talked him into doing it
carl agreed on the condition that it be
published anonymously so use the name mr
x
well i've written scientific biography
before and i can tell you it's the
hardest thing in the world to get
scientists to talk about their sex lives
or about anything aside from from
science pretty much
well the mr x piece is amazingly candid
certainly about the drugs and to a
degree about other aspects of sagan's
life as well so it was really quite
quite a revelation
uh in this mr xp's sagan claims that
cannabis enhanced the enjoyment of
everything from sex to uh to classical
music to baked potatoes
uh
he he seems to think that he was able to
function pretty normally while using the
drug
he even says he sometimes drove a car
while stoned and i should add that
that's something even normal tells
people not to do in these more safety
conscious times
but the most the most unusual thing
about sagan's experiences i think was
doing science while under the influence
now in the mr x piece he writes i quote
i have made an effort to think of a few
particularly difficult problems in my
field when high
i find that it works at least to a
degree i'm able to bring to bear a range
of experimental facts which appear to be
mutually inconsistent
unquote
well rinse moon assured me that sagan
really believed he got many of his best
ideas this way
he remembered one occasion where someone
sent him grinspoon an unsolicited gift
of marijuana and it turned out to be one
of those particularly potent batches
well as soon as carl found out about
that he said you've got to give that to
me i've got work to do
now the inspirations that carl got or
thought he got from the drug were not
always limited to to
astronomy on one occasion carl was in
the shower while high
and had a profound insight into the
origins of racism
well carl believed that this was such a
great idea that it was vital that he
remember it and disseminated
but he knew from experience that if he
didn't write it down immediately he
would forget it and it would be gone so
he grabbed a bar of soap and began
writing frantically on the walls of the
shower
well somehow he got out of the shower
and continued writing on paper
at the end of about an hour he found
that he had written 11 short essays
addressing many of the world's great
social political and philosophical
problems
he reread those essays the next day he
found that most of the ideas held up
pretty well
and he reports that he ended up using
many of those ideas in his lectures and
books
well i should add that sagan was not an
uncritical dabbler in drugs
at about this time lsd was certainly as
trendy as marijuana and it was also
being touted as a source of so-called
mind-expanding insights
but sagan refused to try lsd
his reasoning which he goes into in his
mr x piece was partly that the drug is
dangerous because the dosage is just so
minute that there's really no way of
controlling it in a casual situation
in fact he even applies what you might
call typical sagan logic to this
in the mr x piece sagan proposes a
mathematical ratio to measure the the
risk potential of a recreational drug
now this he defines as the length of
time it takes for a dose of the drug to
take effect divided by the length of
time it would take to consume a
dangerous dose
well if you do the math you find it's
it's a huge high number for lsd for
marijuana it's quite low
and sagan writes that he hopes to see
this uh this ratio printed on the packs
of soon to be legalized cannabis
cigarettes
well of course a lot has changed since
sagan wrote those words
uh more than ever probably marijuana is
very much a hot button in our culture
sagan made grinspoon promise never to
reveal mr x's identity
he surely wasn't ashamed of his drug use
but he was aware that disclosure could
have professional repercussions after
all he had to pass security clearances
for nasa and he was always testifying
before congress
well both men took this vow of secrecy
quite seriously
grinsman mentioned that many years later
sagan's firstborn son dorian grew up and
he read marijuana reconsidered
now dorian was able to put two and two
together he went to grinspoon who had
been practically an uncle to him and ask
him if carl wasn't mr x
but grinspoon denied it he felt he had
to in view of his promise to sagan
there was another occasion where
grinsman wrote an article for the new
york times
he commented that marijuana was being
used by people in all walks of life
kindergarten teachers clergymen etc etc
and he happened to throw in astronomers
well
well when carl read that he was shocked
i mean he was he was upset even by that
very very oblique mention
so you're probably asking how did
grinspoon come to tell me was it turned
out it was one of the things he
mentioned in our very first conversation
together he explained that he hadn't
told anyone about mr x but believed that
a posthumously published biography was
the proper place for it
but he was extremely concerned about how
this information would be presented
he asked me if i used marijuana and what
my views on it were
well i went to high school at the very
peak of the early 70s drug culture
not that i was using drugs i was in one
of the nerdy cliques
we we really didn't know much about
drugs until that is we went to health
class
our health teacher was this 300 pound
ex-marine who showed us these great
anti-drug films
the one i remember best was narrated by
sonny and cher
[Laughter]
[Music]
now it had this segment that was
purported to show exactly what it was
like to be on an lsd trip
i can only imagine that the point was
that this was supposed to be horrifying
and scare kids out of ever using drugs
but all i can tell you is it was
beautiful and imaginative and i thought
it looked great
well all my friends and i agreed that we
had had zero interest in drugs before
but but having seen these health class
films we definitely wanted to try them
well eventually i grew up and i tried
marijuana at least at parties
and it struck me as well maybe not as
good as the health class films but
certainly very enjoyable
uh i should add though that i suppose i
still qualify as a nerd in that
marijuana has never been a really big
part of my life
but certainly as i told grinspoon i had
no problem with sagan's political stance
about marijuana it seemed very well
reasoned as did most of sagan's
political stances
but as i mentioned to grinspoon there is
this tendency to boil any book and
certainly a biography down to the
10-second revelation
and it's one thing for me to devote half
a dozen pages in the book to exploring
sagan's elaborate intellectual rationale
for for using marijuana but that doesn't
prevent the media from exerting this one
factoid out of context and running the
headline like top astronomer or
well the first direct feedback i got on
my book was actually well before
publication
i sent copies of the manuscript to some
of sagan's family and friends for review
uh foremost among them certainly was was
carl's widow and druyan now andrew is a
very open advocate of the
decriminalization of marijuana she
actually sits on the board of normal the
national organization to reform
marijuana legislation
but i knew that she and carl had had a
falling out with the grinspoons
in the last decade of his life
particularly carl could be an absolute
terror to get along with
now i should add that not everyone felt
this way but certainly a statistically
significant fraction of the people i
interviewed did
and in many cases carl would terminate a
literally a decades-long friendship
for reasons that to an outsider seem
pretty trivial
well the upshot was that he and lester
were scarcely talking in the last few
years of carl's life
so i wasn't quite sure how julian would
take to this mr x material
well fortunately she was totally
supportive of my discussion of the whole
marijuana issue including mr x
her only concern was one of balance
she wanted me and my readers to
understand that marijuana was something
sagan used in moderation
and she gave me an example of that that
actually struck me as kind of funny at
the time
she mentioned that carl was also going
on these overseas trips
and he obviously couldn't take the drug
in his luggage when he had to go through
customs so she said that he would often
go for weeks without marijuana
well that struck me as funny because
because it reminded me of the great wc
fields line about traveling the sahara
without a corkscrew and having to
subsist for weeks on nothing but food
and water
now now i know you're saying that's
flippant and it is but but the more i
thought about that the more i realized
druyan's point
we live in a society where a drunk can
be funny and lovable but even the most
temperate user of cannabis is after we
be viewed a lot less tolerantly
i can give you one example from my own
experience
uh i once wrote a book on the great
mathematician john von neumann
now he was notorious for downing a pint
of rye whiskey at one sitting and then
stepping behind the wheel of his
cadillac
now fortunately he didn't kill himself
or anyone else but he had accidents all
the time there is to this day an
intersection in princeton that the
locals point out as von neumann corner
where he had all these accidents
and as far as i can tell no one who read
the von neumann book had the slightest
problem with that if anything it was a
great story that humanized the guy
well between mr davidson's book and my
own i think it's fair to say that the
sagan marijuana story has had its uh 15
minutes of media fame
the media seemed to have found this
mystifying but the stories really
weren't too negative
i suppose the unkindest thing i saw was
in people magazine which ran a review
starting with the claim carl sagan was a
pot-smoking thrice-married spoiled son
even so i have to admit that all three
claims are pretty accurate
one reaction to the book that i didn't
quite expect is that this whole
marijuana story seems to have roughly
split the skeptic movement and as far as
i can tell split them about down the
middle
about half the people i've spoken with
have no problem with this whatsoever the
other half feel somehow betrayed
among this latter group seems to be
sagan's good friend james randy
i read on an internet news group that
randy was saying that well first of all
he wasn't even sure whether to believe
the marijuana stories but in any case he
was very much against any mind-altering
substances
well i think you can make a very strong
and certainly self-consistent case
supporting randy's position
if you want to minimize all risk i think
it's obvious that it's best to use no
recreational drugs at all you may also
feel that
that sober reality is good and any
altered state of consciousness is less
good
that's sort of a personal value judgment
and as such one that i don't think you
can really criticize
but on that latter point sagan clearly
differed from randy he liked the way
marijuana made him feel even felt that
it somehow helped him with his work and
believed that that was justification for
using it
well i think we have to accept that this
is a point on which two very famously
reasonable minds differ
but i'd like to close by by posing the
question
of why there has been such an almost
emotional reaction to this revelation if
you want to call it that that carl sagan
smoke marijuana i think the answer lies
in the fact that drugs are more than
chemicals they carry a great deal of
cultural baggage as well
to most of us marijuana
has certain implications or certain
associations it's probably associated
with hippies reggae liberal politics and
above all defiance for it is illegal
as sagan in particular was very aware
uh the the youth culture that embraced
marijuana was often very suspicious of
science it often linked it to the
vietnam war and and the atomic bomb
well i suspect that this may be behind
the the reaction that i detect from some
skeptics that marijuana is incompatible
with skepticism incompatible in a way
that martinis aren't i guess
but
furthermore marijuana carries the
connotation of hedonism which is we all
know is a very dangerous thought in
american society
we are back to this mr spock idea that
logic and emotion just don't mix
well sagan sometimes struggled with that
mixture himself
his first marriage was to lynn margulis
who of course is now hailed as one of
the greatest of all living biologists
his second wife was linda salzman an
artist and later a tv writer
to some of carl's friends it seemed that
in these two marriages he had veered
from an overwhelming emphasis on brains
to an equally overwhelming emphasis on
body carl saw a therapist as this second
marriage faltered
the therapist finally told him that his
problem was he had to decide between his
brain and his prick
but carl's reaction to that was why
can't i have both
well that type of conflict is something
you see throughout sagan's life and i
think throughout a lot of scientists
lives
in our society pleasure and emotion are
held to be at odds with the logic and
skepticism that are the scientists stock
in trade
now some scientists respond by becoming
emotionally stunted
i suppose i would have to place john von
neumann in that category
but then there are other scientists like
sagan who make a very conscious effort
to strike a balance
in his mr xp's sagan wrote that he first
tried marijuana at a time in his life
when he realized that there was quote
more to life than science
to sagan marijuana seems to have been
emblematic of that other not so rational
side of life
and i suppose to a lot of people not
just scientists that can be kind of a
threatening idea
now sagan was certainly not perfect at
reconciling the the intellectual and
emotional sides of life but he was wise
enough to realize that he could have
both
and i think that's an important key to
understanding sagan as a person and to
understanding why people are upset by mr
x
thank you
[Applause]
thank you william poundstone
the book is carl sagan a life in the
cosmos the publisher is henry holt i
misspoke before sorry clarify that i'm
gonna go straight to uh key davidson to
speak and then we'll do questions and
then we'll do the video to make sure
that we get it all in
in the hour uh keith davidson uh is the
science writer for the san francisco
examiner his book is carl sagan of life
key davidson
[Music]
bill that was a superb speech and uh i
agree with a lot of the sentiments you
expressed in there i think that's a very
good analysis of carl and his
relationship with marijuana and his
relationship with people in general i'm
going to leap right into a somewhat
different topic depending on your point
of view and that is the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence now that's
the subject with which carl is probably
most popularly associated in the popular
imagination i think that a lot of people
have the idea that carl had his own
radio telescope in his backyard and he
was out there listening for radio
signals from other civilizations he did
not actually
but he was certainly a figure who did
more than any single person
of all time to popularize the idea that
the universe out there may be filled
with hundreds of billions of
stellar systems planetary systems some
of which might have intelligent beings
inhabiting those planets beings that
might have the technology and the will
to communicate with us across
interstellar distances much as we might
say to use someone else's analogy
communicate with the ancient greeks by
reading their writings or they might
communicate with us by allowing us over
2000 years to read what they wrote
and next year is a very interesting
anniversary because next year early next
year will be the 40th anniversary the
40th anniversary of the first serious
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
it's a search that was launched by frank
drake who is a famous radio astronomer
who knew carl for many years they were
personally very close
frank and carl were at cornell
university together during a similar
periods of time and frank in early 1960
when i was seven years old
decided to use a radio telescope in west
virginia in a radio quiet valley of west
virginia to scan two stars in the sky
which are pronounced i think taos city
and epsilon aridne any amateur
astronomers can correct me he listened
to these stars for a brief period of
time hoping to detect any kind of
intelligent radio signal coming from
planets that might be orbiting those
stars and the search uh as is well known
now of course was unsuccessful nothing
was heard but that was sort of the
founding event of seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and that
search has since continued uh it's had
many political and economic and
scientific ups and downs in the four
decades since but it continues to this
day
funded
totally or almost totally privately
involving groups such as the seti
institute in mountain view california
and the planetary society and so forth
and
what is the bottom line so far after 40
years well the bottom line is that the
search so far has completely failed
it has completely failed there has been
no detection whatsoever of any
intelligent radio signal from the sky or
at least what we can say is indubitably
an intelligent radio signal from another
civilization
and it is important to stress several
things before i say what i'm about to
say
first of all i'm a very strong supporter
of seti and i have been all of my life
and i think the search needs to continue
and i urge all of you out there who have
a little extra cash to send your
contributions to the seti institute or
the planetary society i have no
connection with these organizations i
don't get a sin
however i do think the steady search is
worthwhile and it should continue
because whatever it finds over the next
couple of decades or centuries or
however long it lasts will be
interesting whether it's positive or
negative but so far the search
appears to be negative after four
decades no signals
and i want to propose today now that
we're on the brink of this 40th
anniversary that it may not be too early
for us to begin to try to draw some
preliminary and i underlined the word
preliminary conclusions from this
negative finding this so far negative
finding
a fascinating thing about seti is that
it poses the most fundamental questions
you can imagine about everything under
the sun questions that are not just
scientific in nature specifically
astronomical and biological but also
sociological economic political and so
forth many of you are perhaps familiar
with the so-called drake equation named
after frank drake the drake equation
which was pioneered in the early 1960s
at a scientific conference in west
virginia at the same radio telescope a
scientific conference where young carl
sagan was present and was described by
everyone present as a brash young man
the same term bill used and that's
correct everybody uses that word brash
young man which meant he was rude and he
interrupted people and he told nobel
laureates they didn't know what they
were talking about that was carl that's
how you become famous sometimes maybe
that's how you do it in american science
but anyway at that west virginia
conference the drake equation was
unveiled frank drake drew it on the
blackboard and it consisted of a number
of variables
that said here's how you might be able
to guesstimate the number of intelligent
radio communicating civilizations in our
galaxy the milky way
the variables in it included things such
as the number of stars in our galaxy
which is pretty well known 300 400
billion the number of stars with planets
which was not at all well known then and
today is somewhat better known although
we still don't really know very clearly
we're still getting data back on the
extrasolar planets of the number of
advanced civilizations out there of
course nobody has a clue
how frequently life is likely to emerge
on other planets all of these things all
of these variables go into the mix and
from this you calculate the number of
likely intelligent civilizations out
there in space that might be interested
in communicating with us by radio and
the estimates that come out of it are
very subjective uh some people who were
present at this 1961 conference had very
low estimates they thought they're
probably very very few other intelligent
civilizations in our galaxy carl was
quite the optimist carl said i think
that there are probably one million give
or take a few
intelligent civilizations out there that
are advanced perhaps more advanced than
we are and are capable of communicating
with us
and
so the drake equation its basic premise
is that if you take all these variables
it can
help you estimate the likelihood of
intelligent life in the universe and
these variables thereby
pose very fundamental questions
questions such as how does life emerge
on a planet for example on the earth
billions of years ago how did the
building blocks the chemical building
blocks of life first appear how did
those building blocks evolve into
self-replicating mutating evolving
microorganisms that then over time
evolved into
intelligent species into us in other
words
how likely is intelligence to emerge on
a planet i mean what is intelligence
these are things actually that are quite
difficult to define when you try to
define them it's like artificial
intelligence when you try to define it
it turns out nobody really knows what it
is like art what is it it's a very
subjective judgment uh what were the
processes that caused intelligent life
on earth to give rise to what we call
high technology and how likely is it
that high technology would develop on
other planets orbiting other stars in
our galaxy
from what we know from anthropology
there's really no guarantee that a
culture will develop in a technological
direction many cultures most cultures
really if you look at history don't move
in a high technological direction many
of them perhaps are perfectly content to
remain stable societies that have stable
economic situations they don't develop
high technologies they're perfectly
happy to maintain a kind of
technological and cultural stasis over
thousands of years and many people would
argue they're a lot happier than we are
maybe most planetary systems out there
in our galaxy are exactly like that
they're not technological they don't
have radio therefore we can't
communicate with them they can't
communicate with us
so in other words the bottom line is
the drake equation raises incredibly
fundamental questions about every
subject you can think about in the
university curriculum and carl sagan's
estimate was a million intelligent
civilizations out there it's an
arm-waving estimate but that's the one
that carl helped make famous and now
after 40 years
the steady searches that have been
conducted
have scanned millions and millions of
stars out there and so far as i said no
indubitably intelligent signals have
been picked up they've been little
little beeps and bumps here and there
but they've either turned out not to be
replicable or they've turned it to have
very mundane explanations ranging from
secret air force experiments to
literally
the firing of
spark plugs in passing automobiles which
send out paint radio signals
and
so we haven't heard a thing after 40
years of searching and what i want to
propose is that it may be time for
scientists to start to harvest the
scientific and the cultural meaning of
this negative finding not that we should
stop searching we should keep searching
but what does it mean that we haven't
detected those signals yet
well
carl sagan was a big optimist on the
idea that the building blocks of life
are likely to emerge on the surface of a
planet he was an optimist about this
because in the 1950s he attended the
university of chicago he was a young
undergraduate and later graduate student
there and while he was there he
witnessed one of the great experiments
in the history of biology now known as
the miller urey experiment after the
scientists who did it stanley miller now
at san diego and harold yuri who was
then at chicago nobel laureate
discovered deuterium and later went to
san diego it's now dead
the miller yuri experiment you can read
about in every high school chemistry
book and some of you may remember
actually how it is done it just involves
a flask you put certain reducing
chemicals in it you add some water you
electrify it electrical discharges you
leave it overnight and it turns out that
you rapidly develop large amounts of
amino acids which are the chemical
building blocks of proteins which are
simple
essential building blocks of life as we
know it
and carl sagan when he was a young
student there went into the laboratory
where stanley miller was doing this
experiment and he saw the flask with
this sort of pinkish coating like
pepto-bismol on the inside wall here it
is it's creating all these amino acids
it's demonstrating that under simple
conditions very much like the early
atmosphere of earth with reducing gases
water and electrical discharges probably
from lightning you can get
the building blocks of life it appeared
that the building blocks of life could
be generated very easily in conditions
that probably existed not just on the
early earth but on planets all across
the galaxy actual actual you know
reducing gases that is hydrogenated rich
gases hydrogen is the most common
element in the universe
so this experiment transformed carl
sagan's thinking about extraterrestrial
life when he was a young person he had
been excited about the possibility of
extraterrestrial life because he read a
lot of popular science and he read a lot
of science fiction uh edgar rice
burroughs in particular uh so he was he
was emotionally ready to accept the idea
of life on other worlds he was also a
big ufo buff which also motivated him
considerably but what really got him
thinking about extraterrestrial life
uh scientifically was the miller yuri
experiment that's what really launched
him he was not directly connected with
it of course but it launched him
emotionally and for the rest of his life
carl i think continue to believe that
the universe
was and is to use a hollywood term
life affirming the universe likes to
generate life when you look out there at
the night sky what you're seeing in
carl's view are just jillions and
jillions of miller-urey type experiments
underway right now in the atmospheres of
planets orbiting alien stars life is
being constantly generated or at least
its building blocks are and because carl
was a great optimist about these things
he also believed that once you created
the building blocks of life that was
pretty much it everything else was
simple
you would then just have a short step to
the development of organisms and then
eventually intelligence with which you
could communicate and
i think after 40 years we can say that
in that sense carl was naive
and i think he began to realize late in
his own life that he was naive
evolution is in fact not that simple
it's difficult to generate the building
blocks of life in real
believable planetary environments
because the universe doesn't just create
the building blocks of life it also
destroys them in the late 50s carl was a
graduate student and he did part of his
doctoral dissertation on the possibility
that miller urey type chemical processes
had occurred in the atmosphere of the
moon which in the early solar system
probably did have a very thin atmosphere
a reducing atmosphere and carl and his
dissertation calculated that these
organic molecules by military processes
would just start piling up on the moon
you know like midas gold higher and
higher and that over millions of years
these would form into
uh through various random processes into
replicating mutating living
creatures and that's why in the 1960s he
and joshua letterberg and a few other
scientists warned that when the first
astronauts went to the moon they might
encounter microbes and they might
accidentally bring them back to earth
where they would wipe us all out so we
needed the lunar quarantine
program that's why they advocated the
famous or infamous lunar quarantine that
was all a long-term spin-off of the
miller urey experiment
and so carl was a big optimist about
this he thought the universe would just
generate piles and piles of life but
what carl forgot was that the universe
also destroys life and over the last 40
years what's one of the things that
we've learned about our universe from
astronomy and from the geological and
the biological sciences what we've
learned is that the universe isn't just
life-affirming it's also life-destroying
we've learned that the history of life
on earth is not just the traditional
uniformitarian tale of life slowly
evolving over millions of years but it's
also comets falling to earth and wiping
out an otherwise perfectly successful
species the dinosaurs
it's a matter of of random processes in
evolution that may never replicate
themselves again and so after 40 years i
think we're at a point where we can say
that the stars are silent partly because
the universe contrary to what carl
thought is actually pretty hostile to
life and that tells us something about
our own future here on earth the more we
learn about astronomy the more we learn
about ways in which we as a species may
have a limited lifespan on this earth
we may be destroyed by a falling comet
we might see an interstellar cloud pass
through our solar system someday i'm
talking about thousands or millions of
years thereby dimming the sun changing
the climate and freezing us all to death
or the thing that carl laid in life as
he got more sober and mature really
began to worry about and that is the
possibility that we may destroy
ourselves that's why in the 1980s carl
became a very visible anti-nuclear
activist he became very active in trying
to stop the proliferation of nuclear
weapons because he began to realize that
the reason why the stars are silent
where we're not hearing greetings from
the heavens may be at least partly
because the universe is full
of destroyed civilizations there may be
millions of planets out there with
civilizations on them but they're the
ruins of civilizations and they're
smoking and they're radioactive and that
may be our fate next and that's why i
think if carl were here today he would
express
on the one hand great relief that since
the end of the cold war we've seen a
substantial diminution in the size of
the world's nuclear arsenals but i think
he would also express great concern
about the fact that we haven't
completely eliminated nuclear weapons
that the superpowers still have
thousands of nuclear weapons in their
arsenals that recently we've seen boris
yeltsin sort of rattling the nuclear
sabers again for his own political
agenda that recently there's been talk
about gutting the anti-ballistic missile
treaty and i think the thing that was
sad and anger carl the most is the us
senate's inexplicable decision
not to accept the comprehensive test ban
treaty so i think if carl were here
today he would tell us although he was
an atheist he might choose to use
metaphorical words he might say that
god hasn't given us
god hasn't given up on us yet
but if you listen to the stars and you
hear nothing their silence may tell you
that god doesn't have infinite patience
with us as well and soon we may also be
wiped off the slate i want to thank you
very much
[Music]
okay we'll take your questions now for a
few more minutes and uh please repeat
the question so uh we have any uh
see we have to uh
uh where we got one way over here but we
got the microphone over there do we have
any over here for right now
uh
all right well you want to just stand up
and boom it out
i'm wondering given that you're immersed
in carl's life
i've talked how many people know him
whether you think the fact that he
wasn't elected the national academy
is um was
an unkind emotional response on the part
of current members who could have
elected him or was a valid intellectual
evaluation of the
the first thing i should probably say is
that he actually was elected in the
initial balloting but the rules say that
they then have uh they then bring this
to the floor in the meeting and someone
can challenge it it's almost like the
thing in a marriage ceremony where you
say you know if anyone knows any reasons
uh speak up now or hold your peace
it was during that that people
challenged him and uh and eventually uh
the in the new balloting they decided to
keep him out
uh the people who are against him
basically felt that he was a popularizer
not someone who actually did science and
that's what really counted against him
but of course there's no strict rules
regarding the academy
i mean people have been elected just
because of their administrative work and
as mr shurmur certainly demonstrated
carl's scientific career if you go by
the number of papers was really quite
impressive and up there with many people
that we revere as great scientists uh
for my money he should be in the academy
do you want to i agree and i think bill
put it very well i agree with what he
said uh i would like to add one thing i
think that it is complicated
the larger question really is how good a
scientist was carl sagan and there's
really no simple answer i think he was a
very solid science he knew a lot about
many different sciences some of them
more deeply than others he speculated
sometimes a little carelessly perhaps
but all in all i think he should have
been admitted and i suspect that one
factor in him being kept out or two
factors is one he could be abrasive
sometimes as bill pointed out earlier
and i think he made enemies he shouldn't
have made and second i think his
anti-nuclear activities cost him a lot
of support among some of the more
conservative members of the of the
academy
yes i'd agree with that as well
i i have a question uh uh
uh this is from anne dream oh yeah and
uh her concern is that uh you both
relied too heavily on lester grinspoon
who had a falling out with carl who has
an agenda against carl
and i'm wondering how you judged
grinspoon's uh commentary on carl as a
person in the context that maybe he was
angry at him or they had this falling
out i didn't say he was angry at him uh
he he said several times that he felt
very honored to have known carl as a
person uh
it was a case i mean he was his best
friend for really from the 1960s until
the mid 1990s
you have to listen to everyone if you're
trying to write a responsible biography
and sort of weigh everything
uh both of them were obviously extremely
wonderful and helpful sources and i just
weigh everything together and try to
write the best biography i can
and uh i i concur i mean andy drean by
the way is somebody i have enormous
respect for i think she had enormous
impact on carl intellectually
emotionally and politically but um
i can only say that
lester expressed great affection for
carl's memory so did lester's son david
who was very close to carl when they
were growing up
there were personal falling outs but
when you talk to these people it's i
mean both of them
urged me not to overstate their
criticisms of carl because as david
grinspoon himself said david's now a
leading planetary scientist he said that
my father and i are very very grateful
to have had carl sagan in our lives and
i think that's one thing that struck me
about i i in two years of research i
never found a single person not one
person who knew carl sagan really well
who just hated him i mean people had
mixed feelings about him some people
loved him and hated him but you know he
had so many wonderful qualities i think
it was very hard for someone to
to for someone's views to be rejected on
the grounds that they just hated him
because i didn't find anybody like that
edward yes but he had his own agenda
we've heard a lot about deathbed
conversion but at the end he was he was
you know calling to god and praying and
all those kind of things can you put
those to rest it's just an urban legend
yeah i mean that was one of the things
julian you know uh certainly made sure
that i was i was very clear on that's
right in fact similar deathbed
conversion stories are told of charles
darwin and bertrand russell one of the
ways
one of the ways that the purveyors of
superstition and flimflammery uh try to
outlast history is by rewriting history
and uh
carl wanted it very clearly known he
remained an atheist to the end he did
not believe in an afterlife annie
herself has very courageously maintained
that point of view publicly and i think
it's a very courageous thing to do
you rightly pointed out that carl sagan
will be best remembered for his
popularizing of science i was just
wondering from each of you what do you
think is most important single
scientific achievement or accomplishment
was in his life or his most important
paper
something i've heard from a lot of
people is his paper on the early faint
sun paradox
this has to do with the fact that uh
that our astronomers know that uh that
the sun has over time uh been burning
hotter and hotter while and if you try
to project that back where you figure
that there must have been a time when
the oceans would have been frozen solid
but the fossil record is very clear that
throughout at least the vast majority of
earth's history there have been liquid
oceans you can see remains uh like of
the ripples where waves came in and were
fossilized so somehow you have to
explain that
uh sagan did a paper back in i'm not
sure what you're saying
yeah uh when he was writing the mr x
piece actually
uh so maybe there's a connection there
pure coincidence but but at any rate
it's been an extremely influential paper
he pros he proposed one possible
explanation for it that involved uh an
evolving greenhouse effect which changed
just in sync to keep the earth uh the
earth's temperature essentially the same
now many other explanations have been uh
advanced since then and no one is saying
that
sagan's was really is going to be uh
judged as the final one but certainly
it's had an incredible influence if you
look at the number of citations this is
certainly one of his most cited of all
papers i agree i think the faint early
sun paradox paper is extraordinarily
important it's beginning to get new
attention james casting among others has
pointed it out as a prescient paper
certainly carl is best known among
scientists for his venus greenhouse work
but it's likely other people would have
wrapped that up sooner or later if carl
hadn't in fact it's certain they would
have um i'd like to suggest that there
are there's a lot of gold in sagan's
research uh i point out in the preface
to my book that there are a number of
prophecies if i may call it that before
a group like this
prophecies that carl made where he had
scientific ideas he and colleagues had
scientific ideas that have turned out to
be correct or may well turn out to be
correct what's funny is the reasoning
process that went into them is often
erroneous uh not always uh carl for
example along with another scientist
whose name i've forgotten uh did some
research back in the 1970s with computer
modeling of the formation of planetary
systems which showed
stephen dahl okay and they showed that
some planetary systems extrasolar
planetary systems might have
extraordinarily large gas giant planets
right next to their suns well now we're
finding all these extrasolar planets and
this completely counter intuitive
prediction is turning out to be true now
was the reasoning process right well
people will have to go back and look at
it but i think this is important for one
very important reason it suggests that
often scientific advances may be made
for the wrong reasons in other words by
going down blind alleys you can often
get to the truth
let's take one more question right there
i want to sort of explore the
characterization of carl sagan as an
atheist i know and everything that i've
read written by carl sagan himself
he sort of was a little more complex on
the issue he said it depended on what
your definition of a god would be
and he had no problem adopting the god
of einstein or of spinoza
and in one essay in 1977 he said that
an atheist is someone that has
conclusive proof that uh that a god
um does not exist and i don't have that
proof so i take the agnostic position
um so i'm wondering how you sort of uh
sort through that and decide based on
everything in totality what what his
beliefs are how they fit
well he certainly wasn't lying when he
said that if you want to to be perfectly
accurate since he doesn't have proof
that there's no god he would be
classified as an agnostic but i think if
you look at the totality of what he
wrote he's basically saying that he
doesn't believe in the judeo-christian
god any more than like the tooth fairy
or santa claus or other things that
strictly speaking i mean you can't prove
they don't exist either so i think it's
almost in that category
i think carl would have said you know
that to say i'm an agnostic about god
would be like saying i am an agnostic
about goblins it would just sound silly
he lived his life as if he were an
atheist so in my book i treat him as for
all effective purposes a practical
atheist he didn't believe in a personal
relationship with god nor did einstein
by that way
despite the frequently quoted comment
about god rolling dice
he carl didn't believe in an afterlife
he didn't believe in a god who saw every
sparrow fall he didn't believe in that
god with whom one supposedly has this
warm personal relationship and so in my
reading he was a practical
atheist well thank you gentlemen the two
books are
[Applause]
you did really well
william poundstone writes about science
for a number of publications including
esquire harper's and the new yorker
henry holt publishes his biography of
carl sagan
key davidson is the science writer for
the san francisco examiner his book on
carl sagan is published by john wiley
and sons
biography on book tv can be seen twice
every weekend here on c-span too
saturdays at 8pm